pues avanza con una noticia de última
hora el comité que se reúne casi que por
última vez vota para que el ex
presidente Donald Trump tenga que acudir
a compartir información sobre lo que se
había de este ataque al Capitolio el 6
de enero del año pasado esta esta es la
primera vez que se le pide al
expresidente que asista a este a estas a
este tipo de audiencias y colaboren esta
investigación que llevó a cabo el comité
de la cámara representantes que
Investiga esta situación sin embargo no
es la primera vez que se le pide el
círculo cercano del expresidente ya han
colaborado en el pasado familiares como
ivanka Trump como yarid kushner y sus
abogados algunos de ellos también de su
círculo cercano durante el ataque al
Capitolio se conoce También en esta
audiencia además de estos vídeos
inéditos Pues que el servicio secreto
estaba al tanto de que simpatizante de
Donald Trump el 6 de enero no solamente
estaban armados sino que habían planeado
actos violentos ese día en el Capitolio
se conoció también que la presidente
Donald Trump pues se firmó justo después
de los resultados electorales órdenes
para sacar las tropas de Afganistán y de
somalia esto dice el comité en una Clara
evidencia de que había reconocido Al
menos internamente que iba a haber un
cambio de administración ha dicho que
pues Estos son pruebas que le van a
compartir al departamento de Justicia
sin embargo que el congreso y el comité
no puede judicializar al ex presidente
Cristóbal continuaremos Será muy
pendientes del avance de este panel y de
esta eventual a comparecencia del ex
presidente Donald Trump pero vayamos
ahora con otro tema y es que
precisamente la Corte Suprema rechazó la
petición del mismo expresidente de
Donald Trump de que un maestro especial
designado una tercera parte revise los
documentos confidenciales confiscados
por el FBI en mara lago que detalles se
conocen de la decisión
Sí precisamente muy cerca al Capitolio
allá en la Corte Suprema eh la Corte
Suprema que es de mayoría conservadora
donde tres magistrados fueron
precisamente designados por Donald Trump
pues votan para que no pueda el maestro
especial designado que es Richard David
acceder a estos 11.000 documentos que
fueron confiscados por el FBI de la
mansión de la Florida del expresidente
en demara Lago y pues esto quiere decir
que entonces la Corte Suprema pues no
acata la decisión y contradice a la a la
juez que había dicho que precisamente el
maestro especial de designado por la
defensa de Donald Trump si podía tener
acceso a esta información son entonces
en noticias de de última hora en una
hora noticias en contra del ex
presidente Donald Trump que pues no
solamente se ve involucrado en esta
investigación de los papeles que se
llevaba sino también que no va a poder
usar Esa esa información y esa
investigación para su defensa